let's smash smash one two three chairs
history did you know how this Jewish I
did until tonight chug this chug this
[Music]
they gave us our dream City of Angels
yes sir hey yo let's solve every murder
no no she's uh she's okay
Congrats congrats to rats Cheers
yes this is Zach's - Joan still got it
after all these years my baby girl you
see the kids - every not cosmonauts and
astronauts to space - underdogs to the
berkland oh god like the Middle Ages
I'm glad we're not in them amen times
are tough but not middle-aged tough not
Middle Ages tots to be vision Rogers and
the good of humanity man scoundrels sis
controls two inventors - everybody -
literally
everybody just Jesus Christ and that's
the end
[Music]